hallo leute heute geht es um die wörter
viel und sehr uns ist aufgefallen dass
diese wörter häufig verwechselt werden
von deutsch lernen und sie sind auch
nicht so ganz einfach
auseinanderzuhalten so hat zum beispiel
unser katrin brian vor kurzem unter
unseren podcast geschrieben
ich habe so viel gelacht über deine
türklingel manuel und in diesem satz
sollte es eigentlich heißen
ich habe so sehr gelacht und warum das
so ist und was der unterschied ist
erklären wir euch in diesem video
der hauptunterschied von viel und sehr
ist das viel
sowohl ein pronomen sein kann als auch
ein abwehr hingegen ist nur ein adverb
beides kann im englischen mit matsch
oder lot übersetzt werden ihr seht
gleich einige beispielsätze aber jetzt
gucken wir uns zunächst mal das wort
sehr an war ich mag dich sehe du bist
sehr lieb meine beiden gitarren mag ich
auch sehr ich spiele sehr oft und sehr
gerne sehr ist ein reines adverb und ein
adverb beschreibt ja immer eine handlung
im fall von sehr beschreibt man die
intensität oder qualität von etwas und
sehr das könnt ihr euch merken dass
steht immer vor dem adjektiv oder nach
einem werk da ich mag dich sehe du bist
sehr lieb meine beiden gitarren mag ich
auch sehr ich spiele sehr oft und sehr
gerne
jetzt gucken uns das wort viel an viel
kann auch ein adverb seien aber meistens
wird es als pronomen benutzt das heißt
es steht anstelle eines namens und fiel
das steht eigentlich als pronomen immer
für quantität man hat viele dinge man
hat viel von etwas hier sind hier ein
paar beispiele
ich habe viele gitarren meine frau muss
mir viel geld geben damit ich viele
gitarren kaufen kann
diese gitarre hat mich viel gekostet
jetzt schauen wir uns viel als adverb an
als adverb hat viel zwei verschiedene
bedeutungen oder variationen die erste
bedeutung ist das etwas oft wurde häufig
passiert ich gehe nicht viel nach
draußen
ich bleibe immer zu hause um viel
gitarre zu spielen
die zweite bedeutung von viel als adverb
ist das etwas stark oder bedeutend ist
und dieses fiel steht meistens in
kombination mit einem komparativ oder
nach dem wort zu dieser gitarre ist viel
besser als diese gitarre aber dieser
gitarre ist viel lustiger als diese
gitarre gesagt dass ich zu viel gitarre
spiele und viel zu viel geld für
digitalem ausgebe carré hat keine ahnung
kommen wir zurück zu bryans kommentar
vom anfang bryant hat geschrieben
ich habe so viel gelacht über deine
türklingel manuel dieser satz von wein
ist eigentlich nicht grammatisch falsch
aber er bedeutet wahrscheinlich nicht
das was du sagen wolltest
in diesem kontext bedeutet das nämlich
dass du oft gelacht hass und dieses fiel
in diesem satz das würde man eher
benutzen wenn man einen längeren
zeitraum beschreibt hier ein beispiel
gestern war ich mit karin eine comedy
show und wir haben viel gelacht was
brian wahrscheinlich meinte ist ich habe
sehr gelacht oder sehr laut gelacht als
er von manuels türklingel gehört hat und
das bedeutet dann dass du sehr intensiv
oder sehr laut gelacht hat darüber dass
war unser kurzes video über viel und
sehr wir hoffen es hat euch geholfen die
unterschiede besser zu verstehen und
wenn ihr noch fragen habt dann solltet
ihr uns jetzt einen kommentar schreiben
und wir versuchen ihn dann zu
beantworten
und wenn ihr deutsch lernen wollt und
zwar die deutsche grammatik schritt für
schritt von a1 bis b2 lernen wollt dann
könnt ihr unbedingt und
feeling ausprobieren dort haben wir
nämlich immer kleine stories kleine
lektionen in denen wir einen
grammatischen bestandteil der deutschen
sprache vorstellen und dann mit
geschichten zum beispiel auch mit
janisch illustrieren
viel spaß beim ausprobieren den link
findet ihr hier unten und hier und wir
sehen uns am sonntag wieder
[Musik]